hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar risk stratification of the
apparently healthy population with
architect stat high sensitive troponin i
i'm christie jewel of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by Abbott Diagnostics to learn more
visit Abbott calm now before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them in the ask a question
box and click send well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab sound at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I now present today's
speaker dr. Gillian Murtagh associate
medical director Abbott Diagnostics for
a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr. Murtagh you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone thank you for the
introduction and welcome to today's
webinar risk stratification of the
apparently healthy population with
architect high sensitive troponin I dip
claimers architects high sensitive
troponin AI is not commercially
available in some countries including
the USA risk stratification claim as it
applied to this webinar for architects
that - to the troponin I is only
available to be used in C II marked
country and in country - our regulatory
registration has been completed my
disclosures I am a cardiologist I
trained across several continents
including the US I have a clinical
background with ongoing research
activities and I have been a full-time
employee of Ovid Diagnostics since 2015
so what is risk stratification of the
apparently healthy population for future
cardiac events with architects high
sensitive troponin I risk stratification
is a tool for identifying unpredicted
who is at risk be that low moderate or
high risk are likely to be at risk and
prioritizing their care in order to
prevent worse outcomes in conjunction
with clinical and diagnostic findings
and those worst outcomes include things
like heart attacks heart failure or
indeed debt why is risk stratification
in this context important we all know
that mortality trends for cardiovascular
disease are projected to continue to
rise and really mortality due to
cardiovascular diseases is extremely
important because deaths from
cardiovascular causes is the number one
cause of death worldwide in both men and
women
and how do we approach risk
stratification
in people who don't have symptoms today
we have multiple risk stratification
tools like Framingham 2008 which
includes age sex smoking history all of
the conventional risk factors we have
scored from the ESC the European Society
of Cardiology we have the pool court
equation from the ACC Naha these are
similar multivariable assessments we do
of course use circulating biomarkers and
we do use profiles such as the lipid
profile and in some institutions high
sensitive CRP which is a biomarker
chronic inflammation and what we do with
those tools is that we determine the
level of risk for future cardiovascular
events people can be either low risk and
in that case we would usually give
lifestyle advice there can be moderate
risk where we would give the same
lifestyle advice but also consider drug
or medications if the risk factors
remain uncontrolled and then you can be
of course high risk and in that case we
would again give lifestyle advice and
indicate it would be very unusual not to
give drug or medications so that's what
we do today however there are
limitations to the current methods in
general they do correlate to the risk of
cardiovascular disease somewhere in the
body in other words they are not
necessarily specific to the heart so one
thing that's important to note is that
it is coronary disease or heart disease
that is responsible for most deaths yet
the tools we are using though they are
extremely important like blood pressure
lipid profile and looking at things like
smoking or whether or not the person has
diabetes there very important that they
are not predicting risk specific to the
heart
secondly they may also be inaccurate
some tools can overestimate or
underestimate a
and cardiac risk thirdly there may be
dependent on age inappropriately to the
point where age can inappropriately
influence the risk status of an
individual so in other words if you have
an older person they would be
automatically categorized as high-risk
purely due to their age and as we know
there are lots of older people whose
risk would not correlate with their exam
stage they may be at lower risk and that
is not accounted for in many of the
existing tools the other issue is that
there are with some of the markers
cut-offs that do put the majority of
people at moderate risk or greater and
we've come to also such as HF CRP an
overly large proportion of the
population may be categorized as
moderate or greater risk depending on
the cutoff used so there are limitations
the other issues include things such as
the fact that soft endpoints rather than
hard endpoints like death were used for
some of the risk calculators with other
rigged calculators such as ACCA H a
family history was not always included
with other calculators such as Q risk
which was compiled from UK data this was
not considered random and there was a
lot of missing data import was included
and of course if you are going to use
something like the lipid profile alone
it would not account for some of the
risk factors that we consider conferring
highest risk like smoking or diabetes so
some of the risks - in other words
didn't always include hard endpoints
some of them didn't always include
certain factors like family history or
treatment of diabetes or blood pressure
which could greatly modify the person's
risk and others simply do not account
for some of the most influential risk
factors
we also know from studies like this one
by de Filippis that are published in the
annals of internal medicine that the
current risk scores such as Framingham
and the accha calculator provide an area
under the curve of around about 0.67
2.71 when it comes to predicting future
cardiovascular events so there are
definitely issues with the current
methods it has been considered that -
CRP could take the form of the primary
circulating biomarker to predict these
events in future but recent reviews have
suggested that it has a limited role in
terms of its predictive value beyond
traditional cardiovascular risk factors
and that it may only be useful for
people who are deemed intermediate or
moderate risk so there are multiple
publications here this one from Folsom
Adele and another from Miller and I'll
where it was shown in the Eric after
cirrhosis risking community sport and in
ending very large US Court that the AUC
was really improved by point zero zero
three on adding HSC RP to usual
cardiovascular risk factors are really a
very small improvement in Eric I mean
Ann Haynes high CRP was rare in the
absence of risk factors so really what
you're seeing is that there was not much
incremental value when you added Hisense
CRP to the traditional risk factors
so risk stratification of the apparently
healthy population we've pointed out
that there is an increasing issue with
cardiovascular disease how can high
sensitive proponent I help
cardiac troponin I is the preferred
biomarker for the diagnosis of
myocardial infarction because at a time
aya cardio tissue specificity as well as
its high clinical sensitivity so we know
that from Corinth I'd lines across the
world troponin I and T are the
recommended biomarkers to aid in the
diagnosis of myocardial infarction and
of course we know that troponin I tends
to be more cardiac specific than
troponin T in many cases troponin
presence has been shown in the blood
stream of apparently healthy individuals
with no clinical signs or symptoms of
cardiac disease and the abbott architect
- troponin i is the first C II marked
cardiac specific biomarker that aids in
predicting future cardiac events and we
are going to explain some of the
evidence behind that it's important to
note that when we compare the avid high
sensitive troponin is a with the
contemporary architecture opponent I a
say there has been a Sevenfold
improvement in precision but without a
significant change to the 99th
percentile and if you look at the
figures here you'll see that the LOD
with the contemporary assay with about
10 nanograms per liter and that is now
about 1.9 nanograms per liter with the -
traffic and importantly the 10% cv
occurred at prairie - and is now
occurring at 4.7 nanograms per liter
however the 99 percentile I'd you can
see has not dramatically changed it's
gone from about 28 to 26.2 and that of
course should not have changed
substantially the general population
that's used for derivation of the 99th
percentile has not changed so we see as
we say a Sevenfold improvement in
precision but not a significant change
to the 99 percentile we do see that with
the contemporary assay we were detecting
about less than 50% of normals with a
detectable value that has really gone up
quite a lot well over 50% with the high
fantastic the percent detection rate of
so-called normal subjects is now well
above 75% for the athlete publications
that we're about to go through and
actually hit well above 95% in most
cases the other issue as we pointed out
there is that it is a highly cardiac
specific I see in that troponin I is
very specific to the heart so what we're
getting us is that the assay has really
provided a big improvement in precision
that you are now able to detect troponin
I and people who are appear to be normal
who do not have finder symptoms and that
it is very cardiac specific when we talk
about troponin I and the use of this
assay as a possible predictor of future
cardiac events and people with no signs
or symptoms you would think that of
course we would like to see that it does
correlate with the presence of
subclinical coronary disease as
determined by imaging techniques such as
say CT or MRI you would want to see that
the higher the troponin value the more
say coronary artery calcification was
present and in this study by alternate
al they took over a thousand people no
known cardiovascular disease performed a
non-contrast CT and demonstrated that
the higher the agate-stone score which
is a measure of coronary calcium the
higher the - troponin I level and that
was the avid - thigh assay here we're
looking at people who were not known to
have had an mi in the last few years but
had a cardiac MRI run now cardiac MRI if
you look at late gadolinium enhancement
you can detect prior Mary cardial
infractions so in this study they looked
at 248 randomly selected 70 year-old
volunteers they looked at the
relationship between the avid - troponin
is a and the presence of lekha Williams
and what they found was that there was
more unrecognized MI the portion was
higher in those with higher - troponin I
levels so to summarize really those two
studies in CT and MRI what you're seeing
is that the - troponin high levels were
player in people with unrecognized
coronary disease or prior mi the values
of of the avid architect stat high
sensitive Capone and I are they really
live in the fact that there is a
substantial body of research that has
shown that this test provides greater
accuracy in identifying a person's risk
of developing cardiac diseases in the
future compared to the current
prediction tools and that's before
symptoms are experienced multiple
studies are available to support the use
of the architecture high sensitive
troponin is a in this context and we're
going to run through some of the more
relevant publications right now so
summarizing the relevant publications we
would look first at say a study like
hunt that was published in 2018 the
first author here was viola Segura
daughter the senior author was turbulent
almond and certainly the hunt study has
provided a huge amount of data in terms
of looking at people with no symptoms or
signs of cardiovascular disease and
looking at future predictions of events
in this particular study the conclusion
was that in subjects from the general
population without a known history of
cardiovascular disease - troponin I
provided prognostic information that was
superior to that provided by - CRP and
may therefore be the preferred marker
for target extension
when we look at the table - here we
looked at associations between -
troponin I and - CRP concentration and
cardiovascular death or admission for
AMI or HF we see that in those with
values that are in the higher risk
categories using the - troponin IFA and
here we're talking as you look at the
bottom of the screen I cut off of 4 or
10 for women and 6 or 12
for men so that those with values below
4 or 6 would be categorized as low risk
those with values above 10 or 12 would
be categorized as higher risk and those
with values between 4 and 10 for women
are 6 and 12 for men would be
intermediate what you're seeing is that
using the low risk at a reference
population those with values of say 4 to
10 or 6 to 12 had a hazard ratio of 4.3
for the occurrence of those major events
am i or HF admission indeed at the
higher levels of 10 or 12 you're seeing
risk of hazard ratio say nine point
seven six so really those numbers were
extremely high even when the models were
adjusted for various risk factors those
hazard ratios remained very high you're
talking between one point eight or three
and varying up as high as we say
therefore four point three or nine point
seven so very dramatic compared in
particular to what you're seeing
underneath and just below the - side you
can see the categorization and hazard
risks ratio is given for - CRP and as
you can see they are higher you know
than the reference population - point
two to two point days in the own
adjusted model but they are not as high
as those obtained for the Hisense is-8
and indeed if you look at the metric
transportation improvement there was a
much greater net reclassification
improvement obtained when using the - i
acid versus the - c or PSA indeed for
hard coronary disease you were looking
at 0.46 or 46% MRI for high sensitive on
an eye and a corresponding sugar for -
ERP with 26% so using those categories
what we saw was that the male-female
risk categories are those as we say that
are included in the package insert the
data suggested that compared to the
Framingham risk score
- troponin I results in a significant
reclassification of subjects to their
correct risk category higher
concentrations of - troponin I in
apparently healthy subjects are strongly
correlated with increased risk of
cardiovascular disease and I've stated
in the publication - troponin and I made
therefore be better suited for
cardiovascular disease screening in an
asymptomatic general population then -
CRP next we're going to look at washed
cups a paper that was published in 2016
derived from that study and that study
was of course the West discussed
encounter prevention study looking at
pravastatin in men with raise
cholesterol this looked at 3,300 men
indeed women were not included I've
loved the case for many of these studies
that were set up a couple of years ago
and in this study they were looking at
five years followed a were able to
obtain 15 year follow up using NHS
databases and the age range between 45
and 64 with the focus this was published
in JAC in 2016 what they saw was that
there compared to the lowest quarter
less than say three nanograms per liter
men in the highest quartile values above
five nanograms per liter where at
highest risk for non-fatal MI or death
from coronary heart disease at five on
15 years with a high ratio of two point
two seven and then when you looked at
the change in troponin concentration at
one year stratified by treatment
allocation and non-fatal mi or coronary
to the DEF at five years there was a
really interesting set of findings
compared as we said to the lowest
quarter people in the highest quarter
we're at highest risk for those
endpoints but indeed there was a five
fold greater reduction in coronary
events when troponin concentrations
decreased by more than a quarter rather
than increased by
more than a quarter and that applied to
both Percy bow and pravastatin cohorts
pravastatin reduced troponin
concentration and doubled the number of
men whose troponin fell by more than a
quarter and that identified them as
having the lowest risk for future
coronary events so this was really a
landmark paper in showing the effect
that troponin could have on how we
approach treatment with statins it
demonstrated that - troponin I can be
used to predict future risk of coronary
heart disease and to assess the response
to start and therapy it showed that
troponin concentrations were reduced by
statin therapy and very interestingly
reductions in troponin concentrations
are associated with better outcomes
independent of LDL cholesterol lowering
heed findings according to that
publication suggest that high central
and AI has major potential to identified
those at greatest risk and to assess
their response as in change at one-year
associated with future coronary risk to
intervention for the prevention of
coronary artery disease see the book
stratify the cardiovascular risk and
guide therapy
when we look at how this could be
applied in practice the troponin could
be used for screening and diagnosis and
high concentrations do suggest an
increased risk of coronary disease in
middle-aged types of cholesterol Enoch
men in terms of cardiac troponin is a
risk stratification values above five
nanograms pretty sure were considered
particularly important and in terms of
guiding therapy and monitoring disease
they were reduced by statin and indeed
the better outcomes that reduction was
independent of earlier
cholesterol-lowering so that was
certainly a very novel finding number
three we will look at a study relation
to the biomarker cohort that was
published in 2016
Capone and I and cardiovascular risk
prediction in the general population so
the photo Taiki here is biomarkers for
cardiovascular risk assessment in Europe
the end here is particularly important
you're looking at a population of almost
75,000 people covering multiple cohorts
across Europe there was 14 years of
cardiovascular mortality follow-up data
available and the mean age was about 52
years
what this study showed was that when
they divided people by troponin high
quintiles with 2.5 being the cutoff for
the lowest quintile and 5.9 nanogram per
you the highest the hazard ratios
reflected that the higher the Hisense
troponin level the more likely these
people were to go on and experienced one
of these adverse outcomes either
cardiovascular mortality cardiovascular
disease or total mortality when we look
at the metric Asif ocation n't you can
see from the top line that for all
cardiovascular mortality in other words
cardiovascular mortality across all age
groups the net reclassification
improvement was 0.048
so you're talking about 4.8% which
doesn't sound to some people like a lot
but when we take into consideration that
the total population of Europe would be
around just over 700 million we could be
talking about reclassifying
approximately 20 to 24 million people
more accurately with the inclusion of -
troponin I what it added to clinical and
diagnostic findings above and beyond
what is currently available so that
would be certainly a very impactful
improvement of note there was an
association of course with selected
endpoints from the Jupiter trial which
is one of the trials that we are going
to go on and discuss momentarily when we
looked at the bottom of the table here
looking at the troponin I category using
cardiovascular disease as an endpoint
and the absolute risk reduction for
those taking rasuu the statins you can
see that for people whose troponin I
level was above 6 nano grams per liter
the absolute risk reduction with 0.74
so in individuals who troponin I was
above 690 grams per liter which with a
concentration near the upper quintile in
that study biomarker and indeed in
Jupiter for the upper quinta with about
5.8 reserva statin therapy resulted in
higher absolute risk reduction
comparable people with values less than
6 nano grams per liter whereas the
relative risk reduction was similar so
indeed the addition of troponin I two
variables with the established risk
score improved the prediction of
cardiovascular death and disease Simmons
what we're really looking at here is a
study that shows that for people whose
values are in the top fifth of troponin
I distribution compared with the bottom
fifth there was really a very
significant increase in mortality from
cardiovascular causes and the risk for a
first cardiovascular event the addition
of - troponin I information to a
prognostic models cardiovascular death
constructive esc score variables in this
publication year didn't enter i of 0.048
which is of course equivalent to 4.8%
and this publication which did involve
as we mentioned almost 75,000 people
demonstrated that the architect -
troponin i assay was reliable in
detecting very low levels of Capone and
I and stratifying feature cardiovascular
risk by use of base cardiac specific
biomarker so it's very important
publication number four we are going to
now talk about another publication and
this time it did include the Jupiter
trial population and of course Jupiter
as we know was justification for use of
statins and prevention it was an
intervention file evaluating roughly
with them so ditched I looked at almost
13,000 people with two-year follow-up
the age for women with over 60 and men
with over 50 this particular sub study
looked at Hisense troponin I and BMP as
predictors of vascular events
environment prevention what you can see
here is that they divided the population
by turtles in men the top turtle value
is about four point six
surrounding up to five milligrams per
liter
and in women the equivalent was about
four nanograms per liter this was
published in 2015 in circulation and you
can see that the cumulative incidence
for first major adverse cardiovascular
event was much higher in people whose
values with above the turtle cutoff that
we just mentioned indeed the hazard
ratios indicated that for the primary
endpoint the incidence rate was much
higher for all of these endpoints taken
together so the occurrence of first mace
in this trial depended upon the high
tense troponin high category and an
individual with high tense proponent I
values in the top turtle there was an
increased risk of cardiovascular
mortality and non-fatal myocardial
infarction secondly receive a statin
which as we know is one of the most
popular sentence was equally effective
in reducing the relative risk of major
vascular events across the categories of
- troponin I but in the highest category
of baseline
- troponin I reserve the statin was
associated with the most substantial
reduction in the absolute risk of
cardiovascular events
now we're moving on to the fifth
publication so you're really beginning
to see a pattern here
emerging whereby - proponent eye is a
very predictive variable we all know
that it's already here
cardiac specific and so this builds on
the evidence that was just presented in
very large populations we did mention a
publication from 2018 on the hunt study
here is one from 2015 of particular
interest to those of us who are
interested in the prediction of
cardiovascular events in women as we all
know women have some disadvantages when
it comes to the currently available risk
stratification models and the diagnosis
and treatment of cardiovascular disease
this study from Hunt which is of course
the appropriate mentor is the North
tron-like Health Study and applied to a
general population again with a
population of almost 10,000 looking at
16 years follow-up at the time and an
age of over 20 when the mean age is
about 50 in this study what was really
interesting was the ROC curves the
ability to HST and I to predict
cardiovascular debt the AUC for men was
0.72 the AUC for women would actually
point 8 4 so when they looked at the ROC
curves of course they were able to
derive optimal cut-offs and again you
see here women to cut off with four
nanograms per litre so you're beginning
to see a pattern of levels around about
four appearing to be predictive in women
and levels here's a 6.7 anagrams per
leisure for men we've already seen from
evidence where five appear to be the
appropriate cutoff so you're seeing lots
of fives sixes and the occasional coming
up towards seven so you're seeing values
averaging answers around six for men so
certainly those five publications were
extremely important but there are
multiple other publications that we do
not have time to review in detail on
this webinar
however we will quickly touch upon five
that did provoke a lot of interest but
if you look into the available data
there are a lot more studies available
i've note from the studies that we would
present overall we're giving you ever
is on over 140,000 being the end all
together when they are added up and
there are studies actually available
across the globe on almost 200,000
people for the application of high sense
troponin I in this situation where
people have no signs or symptoms and
you're looking to predict the future
cardiovascular disease so there's a very
large body of evidence here's an earlier
study from cohorts that made up part of
the biomarker study this looked at
Morgan and checked which is the Scottish
heart health extended court this was
over 15,000 people 20 years follow-up
they were able to show that looking at
cardiovascular events in men on the left
and women on the right the cut-offs here
were again around about the four marks
or 14.7 and seven for men so again
you're seeing these cut-offs beginning
to average Ives across the publication's
those in the highest category the fourth
or top quartile category here values
above twelve point seven overall has 2.5
times the risk of a future
cardiovascular event versus those that
did not have detectable values with
troponin I using the abbott architect
assay we look at thin risk another study
that was a component of the later
biomarker publication and this study was
published in 2014 their category tree
was above about five nanograms per liter
overall and you can see that for heart
failure and overall major adverse
cardiovascular events there was a
significantly increased likelihood of MI
and heart failure and hazard ratio there
about one point one two and one point
one one here's another study that
incorporated men only carefully or caps
published earlier in 2015 this one they
looked at troponin BMP and indeed io six
interleukin 6 and then looking at the
sub hazard ratios across thirds of the
bio mark distributions you can see that
really the higher the troponin value the
more likely they were to have
experienced an adverse cardiovascular
event but again with more evidence for
its predictive value
hi this is a population of patients
around age 70 in this particular study
published in 2013 by
beggars at all and when you look at
older populations you can see that there
are a lot of there are a lot of studies
out there that show that our currency
available models really are very
difficult when it comes to older
populations where we do have some
publications proving that HST ni is
measured using the avid attic and is an
independent predictor of our course and
cardiovascular mortality with adjusted
hazard ratios of between one point four
four for all calls and indeed one point
six six for cardiovascular mortality so
really you're seeing consistent
relationships across these publications
even for older people here's another one
for older people and this of course from
agents which is the population above the
age of 65 men on the Left women on the
right and again you're seeing high
vibrations in the 2.0 five to 2.5 -
range and even when adjusted for
incidence cardiovascular disease above
the top quartile so yet another
publication from the last few years
reinforcing the capability and if we
decided to switch away from men only
studies and look particularly at older
women so as we mentioned there are a lot
of studies that cover men and women
there are some that looked at men only
because of that tendency in the past for
people to look at this disease at a
man's disease which we now know is not
the case but in tight rocks looking at
elderly women there was again a
consistent relationship between
disease-free survival disease Friedman
the disease here being Carney heart
disease and the quartile of - troponin
so if they were above top quartile their
disease-free survival was significantly
less the plane itself as you will see
and to cap off you know we really just
want to look at Boston but in the claim
itself but in the package insert that
you will see the claim as stated for the
architects - - to the troponin I the
statement is that values may also be
used in conjunction with clinical and
diagnostic findings to aid and
stratifying the risk of cardiovascular
disease including cardiovascular death
myocardial infarction
coronary revascularization heart failure
or ischemic stroke an asymptomatic
individuals in the package insert you
will see sex specific cut-offs based
upon the risk level as we stated earlier
from men the cutoff is 6 for low-risk
below 6 for women at below 4 for
high-risk it's above 12 for men above 10
for women and values between that would
be moderate risk when we look at the
package entered again there is evidence
relation to prospective studies it is
important to note that the cut-offs were
derived from published evidence
I think everyone listening to the
webinar today when they look at the
publication's that we've shown will
understand where there was cut off came
from there was a consensus obtained at
an advisory board by an expert panel and
so those cut-offs were derived from
published evidence and a consensus was
obtained as you can see they were
derived from studies that have been
presented within this desk like wasps
hawks by our care hunt Jupiter and
Morgan so we adapted those into the
package insert and you will see those in
what comes out for youth in conclusion
we know that mortality due to
cardiovascular diseases is continuing to
rise in fact we are facing a building
epidemic we know that risk
stratification aims to predict the risk
of a future cardiac event in people in
this circumstance who appear to be
healthy
it's very important to realize that we
are talking about shifting acids that
have been used for years in the
emergency department for the diagnosis
of myocardial infarction in people with
symptoms and for the most part moving
them out of that setting into primary
prevention in other words people who do
not have symptoms at that time current
tools like score and framing them do
have limitations to their youth
the inaccuracy in their predictive
capability there can be an accurate
source in terms of what category they
put people in low moderate or higher
risk and they are not incorporating
cardiac specific variables so the key
really is of course that being a
cardiologist aren't well used to
treating people who already have
symptoms but ideally we would rather
they don't come to us at all
we would rather prevent cardiovascular
disease and outcomes from happening in
the first place so the avid architect -
troponin I is the first C II marked
cardiac specific biomarker that aids in
providing greater accuracy for
estimation of risk to be that low
moderate or high for future cardiac
events in apparently healthy or
asymptomatic people when it's used in
conjunction with clinical and diagnostic
finding very important to note that the
existing risk factors are extremely
important but this provides incremental
value in terms of accuracy in putting
people into a category and it is the
only thing that of course is cardiac
specific there is a very large body of
evidence to support this we've shown you
evidence on what over 100,000
participants and there are multiple
publications that we have shown you and
also other publications that we have not
had time to demonstrate as part of this
webinar you are welcome to go and
obviously survey for yourselves but the
body of evidence is one of the key
things to remember going forward with
this particular assay for all its
complexity in terms of its capability in
its analytic capability it is a simple
blood test so used in conjunction with
clinical and diagnostic finding - third
aid and earlier intervention for
high-risk patients and they avoid
unnecessary tests and treatments and
those who are truly low risk the thing
is that be in a sense a blood test you
do not need a separate blood draw so you
would do this as you would any blood
test used for cardiovascular risk
stratification such as a lipid tunnel it
can be added on to the same blood draw
and it's important to note also that
this is used to put people in the
correct category either low intermediate
or high risk and from there you will use
your local card
these guidelines to treat these people
but with more confidence than before and
so it really empowers patients and
physicians in taking steps in terms of
lifestyle and medication to help prevent
future cardiovascular events thank you
very much
thank you dr. Murtagh for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
okay now let's get started our first
question doctor Murtagh how all the
expected clinicians prescribers for this
test
and a very good question the primary
prescribers for this type of test would
be expected to be primary care providers
such as general practitioners and
internet and other expected prescribers
would include acorus cardiologists
especially those that are involved in
prevention so really we would be
thinking it would be people who carry
out cardiovascular risk assessment a
part of routine care
and who should I run this test on
and another very good question this test
is intended for use in conjunction with
clinical and diagnostic findings as we
mentioned and it would be performed to
complement your current cardiovascular
risk stratification protocol so really
as such you know any patient that you
would usually assess for cardiovascular
risk per your local guidelines would be
a candidate
now dr. Mortimer our next question is
two parts what do you do with the HS
Tian why risk stratification results
such as elevated results and is there
any specific course of action to be
followed
yeah there really did will answer this
em in two parts as well so what do you
do with the results and the specific
course of action so compared to tools
like Framingham ESV score are the accha
foodcourt equations HST and I has been
proven as you've seen with those
publications to more accurately
categorize a patient into low
intermediate or high risk categories
when used in conjunction with clinical
and diagnostic findings so really what
we're saying is that healthcare
providers should use their clinical
judgment and follow the recommended
cardiovascular prevention guidelines to
determine the standard of care that's
appropriate based upon their patient's
level of risk so you know the risk
category and the guidelines that are
followed at your institution for
cardiovascular disease prevention in
technical practice will determine that
course of action that you should take so
it's determined by their risk status so
you treat that patient as as we said low
intermediate or high risk according to
your local guidelines but what's really
important to remember is we don't use
any particular piece of information such
as the lipid panel in isolation when we
look at cardiovascular risk and the same
would apply to high tense troponin and I
it is very important to note that it is
to be used in conjunction with clinical
and diagnostic findings we expect people
to continue to use their clinical
judgment
question should a single measurement be
carried out or serial measurements yeah
very interesting point at the moment the
initial risk assessment is intended to
be done with a single troponin test so
using one of the one architect stack -
troponin I result and that results will
determine the risk category of the
individual so the risk category B that
we said low intermediate or high and the
guidelines that are followed at the
institution whatever institution they
are working on for cardiovascular
disease prevention and clinical practice
that would determine the frequency of
troponin testing so what we are saying
is that for now it would be done using a
single troponin test and you would
follow your local guidelines as to the
frequency of testing
now what about biotin
biases yeah something that is a huge
concern to many of us and so it's
extremely important to note that the
Abbott a say this Abbott high-densit
opponent is a is robust to buy it an
interference which is unlike many other
assays on the market right now and this
is extremely important because as we
know by it and supplementation is really
becoming very commonplace and people
actually may not be aware that they are
taking us because biotin comprises are
an ingredient for a lot of multivitamin
supplements it is used for everything
from Muslim roses to people undergoing
chemo for who are at risk for losing
their hair and indeed it's used for hair
skin and nail health in many women so
actually a lot of people are taking by
it and I know that they're on it but
there are a lot of people who don't even
know they are taking it many assays are
vulnerable to like an interference but
the abbott assay that we're talking
about here is very robust to by an
interference
Thank You dr. merch all we have time for
one more question how does HS TNI risk
stratification compare with the current
tools used by physicians
their current tools if you're talking
about tools like say Branyan 2008 and
the score from the European Society of
Cardiology those involve measures that
are those are very good absolutely as we
said the current you know risk factors
remain extremely important people still
need to take note of their blood
pressure their cholesterol they need to
not be smoking and be very aware of
their diet and exercise but those core
to them they do involve measures that
are not specific to the heart as we
mentioned they predict risk of a screw
after it throws is somewhere in the body
but they're not a signal coming directly
from the heart that may indicate in fact
a hidden risk of future cardiac events
like heart attack or heart failure
they're also in many cases as we said
heavily dependent on age in other words
they're wasted towards the patient age
sometimes inappropriately and which does
not necessarily provide the true cardiac
risk status of a patient so since Roe
Nanaia is specific to the heart we know
that as we showed with those
publications it can more accurately
categorize a patient into a risk
category that they should be in compared
to the above-mentioned tools when used
in conjunction with clinical and
diagnostic findings and we also know
that those measures as we said so this
is something that's really specific to
the heart and really this is providing
incremental accuracy in terms of putting
people into the right category so it's
the type of information the causes
cardiac specific that we've never had
before and so as we mentioned really
it's giving people a lot more confidence
because we know that it actually
improves the accuracy of risk
stratification compared with current
tools when it's used in conjunction with
clinical judgment
thank you dr. Murtagh do you have any
final comments for our audience
we are looking forward to working with
health care institutions and physicians
to introduce this indication and I think
we would welcome further questions on
this matter and we are delighted to have
the opportunity to present this data to
the audience today and thank you very
much for your time thank you again dr.
Murtagh now before we go I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions and
I'd also like to thank laborat and our
sponsor Abba Diagnostics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
june of 2019 lab routes will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thanks for joining us goodbye